quelques flocons en début de matinée ce
mardi mais nous sommes loin des 5 cm
prévus par météo france
environ un centimètre de neige est
tombée dans le département les saleuses
sont pourtant sorti cette nuit jusqu'à
minuit et elles ont repris leurs
rotations ce mardi matin
bah ce matin un peu d'un peu de glace et
là rebelote la neige qui revient donc
envie de repartir
combien de sa douce qui partent là la
nama neuf on en a une qui tourne
actuellement sur montigny 1200 tonnes de
sel sont à la disposition des équipes à
l'entrée de la période hivernale
il en reste aujourd'hui 900 tonnes de
quoi faire les équipes sont mobilisables
dans les prochains jours car la neige
pourrait refaire son apparition en fin
de semaine la nuit prochaine les
températures vont bien descendre on aura
notamment demain matin -4 et -6 degrés
donc effectivement les chaussées vont
geler et les phénomènes glissants seront
présents encore demain matin et le matin
jusqu'en fin de semaine on descend
jusqu'à -6° et on a une petite
dégradation pour vendredi avec l'arrivée
d'une perturbation par l'ouest les
températures dans le département sont
inférieurs aux valeurs moyennes de
saison
elles chutent la nuit jusqu'à -6° alors
qu'elle devrait être positive et dépasse
péniblement les 2 degrés en journée une
sensation de froid accentuée par un vent
de nord nord-est
le redoux est attendu mais pas avant
mardi ou mercredi prochain